[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
we've got something really interesting
and a little different for you today so
in the wake of everything that happened
in Charlottesville a few weeks ago while
we were actually on summer vacation
tensions have remained really high
around these debates over whether
Confederate statues in cities around the
South should be removed or whether they
should stay and the statue debate is
sort of centered around statues honoring
Confederate leaders or Confederate
soldiers or states of the Confederacy
and any serious person at this point
realizes that the main point of the
Confederacy's actions in the Civil War
were to preserve slavery right and they
will sometimes say well it was about
states rights but one layer below that
is that it was about maintaining a
state's right to have slaves regardless
of what the federal government said and
if you look back at the economies of
many Confederate states you'll realize
that they were totally dependent on
slavery periods so that the sort of
academic debate at the time over states
rights was very low on the list of
priorities compared to the reality that
if they can't have slaves anymore it is
going to impact their economies and if
you look at the timing of when the
Confederate monuments and statues were
put up it was around number one around
1900 between 1900 1920 when states were
enacting Jim Crow laws to discriminate
against black people and segregate
society and then you had another wave of
it in the 1950s and 60s as a direct
backlash to the civil rights movement so
even if you could argue sort of
academically that the Civil War wasn't
about slavery which you can't because it
was you can then look up what motivated
putting the statues up in the early 20th
century and in the mid 20th century and
you can very quickly see what this is
about okay so over the weekend there was
a neo Confederate anti-government
militia organization in Tennessee that
calls itself the new Confederate States
of America they traveled to Richmond
Virginia and they held a demonstration
in front of Richmond's statue of
Confederate General Robert E Lee and
there are actually several statues of
Confederate leaders in Richmond Virginia
and these far-right demonstrators came
and
port of leaving every statue where it is
there were only a few dozen of these neo
Confederate protesters who showed up
most of them were openly armed not
surprisingly but it did provoke a really
big peaceful counter protests by
thousands of people in Richmond who are
in favor of taking the statues down and
what's most hilarious about this
grouping coming to Richmond is how
counterproductive the decision was all
that these neo Confederate protesters
succeeded in doing was sparking a huge
counter protest in support of removing
the statues which outnumbered them by
about a hundred to one they created
awareness for the opposite cause and I'm
showing some of the video of the counter
protests on the screen this has been
gathered by producer Noah Ferguson
working alongside Mike Shea down in
Richmond Virginia
Richmond if you if you're not aware of
the history of Richmond there's a very
long and tumultuous history when it
comes to race relations Richmond was the
capital of the Confederacy during the
Civil War Richmond was the largest slave
trading hub on the East Coast during the
19th century once slaves were kidnapped
in Africa and sent to the east coast of
the US Richmond was usually the first
place they stopped and there they were
confined auctioned off typically to
other slave traders who would then
distribute these slaves throughout the
south of the United States historians
and anthropologists say that most
African Americans today would be able to
trace their ancestry to Richmond
Virginia and because Richmond was the
capital of the Confederacy
there are huge monuments memorializing
Confederate leaders in the heart of the
city including as I mentioned Robert Ely
president of the Confederacy Jefferson
Davis there are high schools in Richmond
named after these people and for years
there's been a lot of debate at both the
state and local level about removing
these statues in Richmond Virginia and
after the events in Charlottesville
Richmond's mayor levar Stoney said that
the Richmond City government should
consider removing the monument so this
militia group shows up in Richmond on
Saturday
counter-protesters show up absolutely no
violence from counter protesters right
we did a long-form piece recently about
the myth of the violent left the left
were not the violent ones in
Charlottesville and they were not
violent in Richmond Virginia either
seven people were detained four of those
were detained for wearing masks in
public which is illegal by statute in
Virginia so I want to get to some of the
interviews with these folks here and
Noah Ferguson and Mike Shea doing a
really really good job on the ground in
Richmond Virginia let's start with some
people who like the statues and say
states rights as a refrain as to why we
had the civil war in the first place
what about the people that wish they had
the freedom to take the statues down
because to them it represents slavery
and oppression why would it right and be
slavery and oppression it's it's not
anything to do with slavery right I mean
history books if you read in the history
books it was state sovereignty mm-hmm
and then we've also got another example
of people talking about states rights
let's take a look at that one what about
the people that when they come down this
Avenue they say it reminds them of
slavery of being oppressed go up next to
haven't you don't come down this Avenue
if you don't like it go up the other
Avenue right now as I mentioned earlier
lots of people were armed
why were they armed here's one guy
explaining why he's armed
I see you're armed today why did you
bring a gun Second Amendment to the
Constitution Britt named by Thomas
Jefferson it's specifically iterates
that we have the right to bear arms to
protect ourselves from enemies both
foreign and domestic who are your
domestic enemies that would be an
out-of-control federal government what
about President Trump I believe in what
Trump's doing oh yeah I think he's good
he's a businessman ah this guy quotes
from Thomas Jefferson on the Second
Amendment
he also gives this line about well my
domestic enemies are tyranny by the
federal government that's often
attributed to Thomas Jefferson that line
has not been found in any of Thomas
Jefferson's writings period now with
this guy care about that no he wouldn't
and clearly this
guy is the sort of ideologically
committed trumpets that we've talked
about now here's another couple of guys
one who says that counter protesting is
something that people do only when
they're in Kenny garden also this guy
equates Confederate generals to Abraham
Lincoln and defends slavery
take a look I'm here because I would
like two monuments to stay getting out
here and yelling and screaming and
acting like you're in kindergarten or
something others not doing nothing it's
just making people hate you more if you
don't like it or agree with it
look you got Lincoln up there I don't
like him I don't agree with that let's
take that down
I don't like Lincoln because of what he
stood for and what he tried to do and
for his Northern Aggression war that he
put onto the south to take our rights
away slavery has gone on since the Ice
Age you know what was the Civil War
fought over it wasn't fought over
slavery that's for sure
that's just the best there's been
slavery since the Ice Age so Lincoln was
wrong
also people counter protesting okay Noah
and Mike did try to talk to some of the
anti foot types but they actually
received death threats for wanting to
film them so here are non anti feh
counter protesters that Noah and Mike
spoke to actual African Americans
explaining why the presence of these
confederates Confederacy era monuments
is not good for them take a look at this
what do you have to say to the people
that say hey this represents my heritage
so I'm telling
I'll tell those people their heritage is
based on treason because those people
fought against the United States that
makes them traitors they are not heroes
they didn't do anything but make causes
huge four-year war they killed a lot of
people all right here is another counter
protester talking to Noah and Mike in
Richmond Virginia
well the monuments represent hate you
know they represent a terrible past in
this country and I think they should be
removed and put in a different place
like a museum you know or like some of
the burial grounds cemeteries that's a
better place for them not right in the
middle of our cities all right and so we
need to move them to where
should be where they can be looked at in
context now looked at in the 21st
century all right and here's just
another couple of counter-protesters
we'll hear from them as well what do you
hope to accomplish with this March we
hope to awaken some of these white
extremists
well this allure is clearly about
slavery people who say it's not our
dissembling so listen the civil war is
over right these protestors claims about
history are just wrong doing this and
saying these things in Richmond of all
places is sort of the height of
absurdity now on the issue of whether or
not slavery was the central issue of the
civil war are these people just
uninformed is this an educational issue
are they victims of filter bubbles and
echo chambers I've been talking a lot
about that in the course I'm teaching at
Boston College and ask yourself this why
do the four years of the Confederacy
warrant so much commemoration in
contrast to the other 400 years of
history in the south right why does the
Confederacy hold such a special place in
the hearts of these people is it because
it was sort of the last stand for states
rights not really I mean we've had
endless Supreme Court decisions in favor
of states rights since then so why is it
it's hard to make an argument Pat that
it's about anything other than a sort of
melancholy reminiscence about slavery
and where else in the world can you find
this you're talking about a campaign of
people who attack their own country
responsible for over 600,000 deaths all
for a putrid reason as slavery was and
then they get commemorated for it 150
years later it's like a participation
trophy and here is the connection to the
modern politics of 2017 what we're
seeing is people emboldened by Donald
Trump period that's why this is
resurfacing and we need to beat it down
figuratively right I'm not advocating
for violence but it needs to be beaten
down peaceful counter protests are a
tool and I don't agree with those who
say hey ignore white supremacists
because all they wanted is attention
you've got to connect the dots here
right you have to understand how the
rhetoric of the President of the United
States connects to not
the resurgence II in white supremacy as
we've heard of from from former
neo-nazis and KKK members on the program
but how it connects to policy proposals
right the Muslim country travel ban the
Mexican wall white supremacist terror in
Charlottesville you can't in any real
way deal with that by ignoring the
neo-nazis you you just can't and you
know burying it in terms of discussion
will actually provide cover to the
elements out there and they exist that
want these policies to go forward so I
encourage you do not do it send me your
thoughts on Twitter what you think about
these interviews and we will continue to
having this conversation because it's a
really important conversation to happen
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter is david patten show the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is called well do get into the third
called well thank you so much for being
a david pakman show member we are a
viewer and listener supported program i
implore you if you like this show if you
want to support the work that we do
please consider throwing us a few bucks
a month either through membership at
david pakman.com slash membership or
through patreon at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and also remember if
you ever shop on amazon.com the shopping
you do can support the work we do if you
go to david pakman.com slash amazon
every time you shop so here's an
interesting little story a letter i
received we did a story a couple of
weeks ago called what are crazy reasons
people have canceled memberships and
among some of the different stories i
told i mentioned a guy who emailed me
saying david i like your show I like
what you do I agree with your politics
but you are a bachelor and I am a
married man with three kids and were
about the same age and I disagree
conceptually with taking money away from
my family to fund your bachelor
lifestyle but great show love the show
will continue to watch and my reaction
was listen that's totally fine I decide
whether to support a worthy causes
financially based on the merits not the
marital status or family situation of
the other person or of my situation but
hate to each their own I got a very very
nice letter which I'm gonna put up on
the screen for you from Christy and I'm
not gonna mention Christy's last name
there's many many Christy's doesn't
matter this is just someone who wrote to
me who said David I heard you talk about
a person who wanted to know how you
could ask for money from single moms to
support your bachelor lifestyle well I
listened to you on the radio every day
I've been wanting to become a member for
months but I haven't yet I am a single
mom of three kids no support from the
father 1 child of special needs and
requires therapy and I can't work a
traditional job so I do whatever small
jobs I can and I'm starting a business
this fall but I heard you say that this
guy said this and I became a member
today I may have to cancel at times and
then come back but that idea ticks me
off because you aren't trying to sell me
something I don't need to trick me into
giving up my money I need for my family
so that you can get rich I rely on your
show and other progressive shows like it
to know what's happening so I can plan
how to defend my kids from what's
happening around us just wanted you to
know that families like mine do value
your show thank you for everything that
you do what a nice letter from Christie
and there are many people you know there
are many many people in our audience who
make a lot of money and they don't
necessarily support the show financially
and that's fine there are many people
who because of their financial position
understand the importance of the issues
we're talking about and the issues were
activating around and that's why they
support us and I could not thank Christy
enough what a nice letter and I
encourage you join Christy the support
the work we're doing it is a tough time
for the show we've got patreon even just
$1 a month through patreon means a lot
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
membership is available david pakman.com
slash membership there's a coupon code I
voted 17 whatever works for you whatever
amount works for you don't think that
because you can't contribute much it's
not worth contributing at all because
through many small contributions we've
built the program that we've built I
want to talk about what happened in
London on Friday there was an explosion
on the district line train at Parsons
Green tube station to being of course
the British subway it's being treated as
a terrorist incident by London police 30
people were treated in hospitals or
urgent care centres
it was mostly burn injuries 19 of the 30
were taken to the hospital by ambulance
11 were in ok enough condition to take
themselves to the hospital or to Urgent
Care Isis almost immediately claimed
responsibility through an affiliate but
that's really no surprise and
amber Rudd who's the Home Secretary in
England says that there's no evidence of
any actual connections to Isis beyond
maybe you know a shared ideology the
perpetrators were not initially
apprehended so there there was a manhunt
an 18 year old and a 21 year old have so
far been arrested unclear whether these
are the perpetrators or were involved
with the incident in some way and what I
want to talk about is the true very real
and very serious danger that Donald
Trump's reaction to this event and two
other events are having Donald Trump
tweeted very shortly after the incident
before we really knew much at all about
what had happened quote another attack
in London by a loser terrorists these
are sick and demented people who were in
the sights of Scotland Yard must be
proactive this contains all sorts of
really dangerous stuff first of all
public criticism of a major ally before
we even have any information it's a
diplomacy disaster absolute diplomacy
disaster and for now
diplomacy still sort of matters British
Prime Minister Theresa May called the
comments not helpful you think that's
what she wants to be dealing with or
what we want to put her in the position
of having to deal with after a terrorist
attack in her country immediately
this causes Trump's lieutenants to have
to go and do damage control
National Security Adviser HR McMaster
came out and said what the president was
communicating is that obviously all of
our law enforcement efforts are focused
on this terrorist threat for years what
does that mean adding Scotland Yard has
been a leader as our FBI has been a
leader Trump then followed up minutes
later and we'll get to some of his other
tweets but this brings us to the facts
right is it true that Scotland Yard had
these perpetrators in their sights we
don't know the answer to that if so was
that classified information again
classified information from an ally
shared with us not to be made public
that Donald Trump goes on Twitter
and tweets but interestingly enough the
answer might actually be a lot dumber
than any of that 23 minutes before
Donald Trump tweeted that Scotland Yard
was aware of these perpetrators Fox and
Friends on Fox News had a security
analyst saying that he feared that the
London police already had the identities
of the attackers feared that they might
know the identities is of course nothing
like have been tracking these particular
people for some time so either Trump is
spreading rumors that the attackers were
in the sights of Scotland Yard or he's
leaking information yet again that he
has no right to leak
it's disturbing for a 71 year old man to
be doing this particularly if he's
President of the United States
minutes later Trump goes back to Twitter
as part of this demented rant two
minutes later and he tweets trying to
defend the travel ban saying quote the
travel ban into the United States should
be far larger tougher and more specific
but stupidly that would not be
politically correct based on what was
known then what actual data do we have
that the type of travel ban that Donald
Trump wants in the United States would
have actually prevented this attack in
London we have none but this influences
policy people see this stuff and they
believe yeah look at what happened in
London we should have the travel ban hey
just ban all travel right I mean no one
can blow anything up if there aren't
passengers and why wasn't Donald Trump
this mad about what happened in
Charlottesville then he needed time to
think calmly about his response and then
Donald Trump to game at the internet
saying on Twitter quote loser terrorists
must be dealt with in a much tougher
manner the Internet is their main
recruitment tool which we must cut off
and use better hell yeah I mean banned
the internet right Pat that's how they
recruit except for the online stores
where you can buy Donald Trump's Magga
hats that are made in China other than
that we've got to shut down the internet
for these folks it's interesting that
you bring up that Charlottesville point
too because he said at that time that
when he makes a statement he wants to be
correct and he wants all the facts on
the ground
ending on it remember you would say the
same thing over and over again like
there's good people on both sides
there's bad people on both sides not
here repeating himself trying to defuse
the situation but for this one he's
willing to rush to judgment minutes
after and minutes after he hears
something similar on Fox and Friends and
what really scares me about this is that
Trump is using sort of a failed I mean
30 people were injured it's terrible it
could have easily been much much worse
Trump is using an effectively failed
subway attack in London to justify a
ridiculous travel ban in the United
States
what would Trump do if we actually had
and I hope we don't have it a major
domestic terrorist attack if he uses a
failed attack in London to justify
hairbrained policies what is the guy
capable of if we have a major attack in
the United States this is not American
exceptionalism this is the growing
realization from foreign powers both
friendly and unfriendly that Donald
Trump is a livewire that he can't be
trusted and that's something that our
allies Trump doing this after a close
ally has an incident allies would see
this and rightly say we've got a
distance from the US we just don't need
this right now
and it's also something that plays into
the hands of our adversaries our
adversaries would also use against Trump
that the guy is unhinged and can't
control what he says in social media the
Twitter rant when you read it pat and
you consider there's been an attack in
London right if you take a tweet in
isolation it's easy to write it off and
say it's Trump being Trump he says
what's on it's on his mind except when
it's Charlottesville and it would make
sense to be quiet for days the rant in
total is the ranting of a true madman
lunatic that's the reality of it I
really think that he could avoid half of
the trouble that he gets into if he just
deleted the Twitter account or delegated
it off to someone else and why is he
continues to beat himself over the head
with this it's just unforced errors time
and time again that applies to the
Russia investigation right I've talked
about that a lot of what's going on with
Russia is related either directly or
indirectly to subjects that Donald Trump
has broached on Twitter if you saw your
local supermarket manager tweeting stuff
like this on Twitter
you'd look at replacing the supermarket
manager because it's unhinged and it
really doesn't look good this is the
President of the United States who is
going on these rants and still has and
actually you know his his approval
rating has been ticking up I don't know
if he related this oh it's disturbing I
looked at the Gallup daily tracking poll
he hit a low there of about thirty four
thirty five percent it has been steadily
higher I mean it's still not great right
but it's been solidly close to 40 now
for about ten or so days I might talk
about this tomorrow I don't know yet but
there there is a contingent of the
country that is not going to turn on
Donald Trump and that's why we can't
wait for people to just wake up right I
mean we were waiting for people to wake
up all of the george w bush's first term
guy got reelected maybe it's because
he's been working with democrats a
little bit more and i think it had been
a little bit of time since his last
twitter rant yeah anytime that you can
get some distance from twitter that's
worth a one and a half to two and a half
approval points no doubt about it this
is really scary and it's not about you
know i know we like to put up tweets and
we laugh right because it's also silly
that this should be concerning to
everybody this is now a national
security concern for the United States
Donald Trump treating allies in ways
that if we were them we would say look
at how we're being treated by the
President of the United States we need
to stop sharing information with them we
need to reconsider our alliance with
those countries and I know that there
are trumpets who believe we don't need
anybody else we're the best and Trump
can do it all in our national security
and military we can do it all but this
is eight an entire planet and we do
actually need the support and alliances
that we have and seeing Donald Trump
single-handedly destroy them day after
tweet after day after tweets should
scare all of us because what because of
what it means for the future of the
United States
discuss this with us on reddit david
pakman.com slash our EDD item the david
pakman show at david pakman.com welcome
back to the David Pakman show
I'm welcoming to the program today James
d'amour who's a former senior software
engineer at Google he was fired for
writing an internal document that
criticized the company's culture and
diversity practices so James you've
really been doing the interview rounds
lately and as as some of our mutual
Twitter followers have pointed out that
they've seen you mostly do interviews
with I guess what would fall under the
umbrella of right-wing media but as far
as I understand that's not because
that's what you've been seeking out
right right I've really been giving
interviews to most of the people that
have asked and it just happens that I
get very few long-form interview
requests from people they would identify
on the left
why do you think that is like in other
words why has there been this sort of
what why do you believe there's been
more interest from the right in
interviewing you well I did give several
interviews to CNN and Bloomberg does
this insider and so I did give
interviews to left but I feel like they
were very hostile and the audience's
reaction it was actually they were on my
side and so it didn't look good for them
when I gave interviews that that may be
one and I think they're just not willing
to really engage me in any long court
discussion because what I'm saying
doesn't fit their narrative that's
interesting so and so one of the things
you're saying is it's possible that the
left has not been interested in
interviewing you because it hasn't gone
well for them
yeah that's at least one theory that I
have that's interesting and in what way
has it been reflected that it didn't go
well I mean
certainly I think if you asked for
example CNN about it and you said hey a
lot of the people a lot of the audience
sided with James d'amour I would be
shocked if they said yeah we can't have
that that's not good for us if people
side with James so in what way do you
think it was reflected that it didn't go
well for them well it just seems like
they're not fair maybe I I just based on
the comments a lot of people would
dislike their videos and point out how
they just didn't like how they treated
me interesting well let's get into I
reviewed the the memo you wrote again
this morning in preparation for our
interview and you'd there's been very
general sort of assessments made of this
memo that was the start of you
ultimately being fired by Google there
are those who describe it as a sort of
evidence based document about gender
differences others say that you're
perpetuating gender stereotypes what
would you say is sort of like the
primary thesis of your document about
Google's diversity policy so I think a
lot of our culture is really intolerant
to ideas that don't fit their ideology
and I was trying to present the ideas
that really go against some of the less
biases and use that data to try to help
us increase diversity so look at the
ways in which psychology has shown that
men and women differ on average and
perhaps make our culture and our working
environment more appropriate for some
women and what would be an example of
how workplace a workplace and if you
want to make it specific about your
former employer Google and even as your
department within Google I'm sort of
fine with that that might be interesting
what might be a change you'd suggest to
make the environment more appropriate
for women as you described yes sir if we
just look at some of the average
differences women being more cooperative
and sometimes less assertive we can
really try to promote people that are
and so those that help on multiple
different projects without being the
team lead for a particular project
because in our performance reviews it's
really looked positively if you're the
team lead and it's it's hard to judge or
if you're someone that only helps on the
project and also you know we can
restructure our team meetings to really
make it so it's not just the most
assertive person talking the entire time
that's interesting and so it is and to
be makes you make sure I'm understanding
what you're saying would it be
are there specific gender differences
you've identified that would make women
sub-optimal to be team leaders in the
way in which they would be expected to
be at Google I think maybe yes there are
some expectations that are put on Team
laids that we expect them to be more
masculine in some ways and that may not
be relevant to their actual work
performance and so that we should
probably change and in your estimation
in the research you've done do you
believe that that difference between men
and women in that particular sense you
know you mentioned this assertiveness
thing you also talked about women being
more prone to anxiety in the document
that you wrote do you believe that those
differences are biological or sort of
cultural nature or nurture as the phrase
often goes yeah I think there's a
combination of both and it really they
combined and it's really hard to
disentangle lunk on the other but you
know there are reasons to believe that
there are biological roots to a lot of
these for example women with prenatal
high prenatal testosterone has many
masculine traits and even within the
world different cultures have different
gender gaps in this but it's that the
societies that treat men and women more
similarly those had the largest gaps so
the more prosperous countries seem to
allow men and women to act how they
normally would
talk about what do you normally would
what would be the baseline for normality
in terms of gender behavior in your mind
yes so I maybe normally is not the right
word but just if you need to act a
certain way to even survive then then
you may be doing that and so my one
example that's relevant to stem is that
even within the United States if you
look at the lowest socio-economic status
there's actually not really much of a
gender gap in stem but then when you go
to the higher economic says there's a
much larger gap so men it stays about
the same but women drop out and go into
a social work a lot of times and so
there's sort of an economic necessity to
go into stem because it's high paying
when you're a lower socioeconomic status
but oh if you're a richer then you
really don't need to work in stem if you
don't want to and James you mentioned
that some of the gender differences
could be related to sort of like what
people need to do to survive in 2017 do
you think that it's a matter of survival
these gender differences like
assertiveness and anxiety in corporate
culture for example is can we really
point to survival as the necessitating
factor between those differences I'm not
necessarily survival but really what you
want in life and you know people
generally if they start out poorer and
they generally do want to be richer
right yeah I mean I guess I guess that's
a very general statement yes if you if
you were poor you probably would rather
would rather not be poor you know I I'm
very interested in this topic and I
found that the reaction when Larry
Summers at Harvard had said something
about you know figuring out if there are
differences between men and women when
it comes to predisposition to math or it
was something I actually don't remember
exactly but I remember thinking that
some of the initial reaction was sort of
overblown because I do think it would be
really important in society to be able
to explore that like why wouldn't we
want to
if indeed there is something biological
that makes men or women predisposed to
excel or struggle in certain areas but
to take one of the things you just said
this idea that in countries where men
and women are treated more similarly you
see larger gaps in some of these areas I
did a quite a bit of research over the
last week and what I found was that the
more egalitarian a society is the
smaller the gender difference has become
in terms of performance in science and
math so in other words when when one
example would be a Villanova University
psych department study called cross
national patterns of gender differences
in mathematics what they found that was
when women were most secure and affirmed
that the difference between their
performance in math and science and that
of men almost goes away completely and
that seems to be at odds with what you
said no sir I'm not really interested in
the actual ability of men and women it's
more the personality and in those
societies that personality is what
diverges the most and so a lot of the
reason why there's a gap in stem is not
that women aren't necessarily worse in
math or science you know women are
actually doing better than men in pretty
much every field in in schooling but
they just choose to go into different
fields at some point and you know one of
the largest reasons why there are fewer
women in these STEM fields is that yes
men and women have about the same
quantitative ability on average but
women tend to have higher verbal ability
and especially among high performers men
are much more likely to be only good at
math and quantitative things and not so
good at how women are more likely to be
well balanced and if you're well
balanced and you don't need to work in
stem you can work in law or other fields
that are required for mobility while the
men really just need to work in stem now
that's very interesting to me because
correct me if I'm wrong part of you
criticism of the Google diversity policy
was that it was trying to sort of impose
some kind of hiring equality 50/50
equality between men and women that
might not correlate with what you
believe might be the best fits but what
the argument you just made which is
listen there are lots of men who were
only good at math they're not so good as
women at verbal skills so by over hiring
women in the departments where being a
good at math is sort of a prerequisite
you would be hurting men's op
opportunity to be hired isn't that just
the exact policy you're against just
meant to disproportionately hire men in
these departments like it I'm hearing
the exact opposite of the policy you're
criticizing all right sorry I I don't
see how that's exactly the opposite I
I'm really just saying that if in a
world without any discrimination and
where we treat men and women exactly the
same we wouldn't expect fifty fifty
percent of women interested in working
in tech and that was largely the thesis
that I was trying to counter in the
document because that is something that
I heard over and over again at Google
that oh if only we were able to get rid
of all the sexism then we would have
5050 okay but my point was if you're
saying listen women are really good at
lots of other types of jobs by virtue of
having better verbal skills as you said
and there are lots of men who wouldn't
be good at those jobs therefore we
should be hiring more men when being
good at math is the sole prerequisite
isn't that the same type of sort of
direction of saying we need to hire more
men because they're not going to do as
well in other jobs but you're being
critical of the hiring of women for the
exact same reason I don't I'm not sure
if I'm expressing myself clearly but is
that does that make any sense I'm really
not saying that oh we should hire men
because of this I'm just saying we
shouldn't discriminate when we're hiring
and if our natural hiring like we
wouldn't expect women that are both good
at math and verbal to necessarily choose
down and we shouldn't uh like we sort of
infantile wise women in this way where
we say that we know what's best for you
and even though these women are choosing
to not go into stem we're sort of
guilting them because oh you you can
work in stem you know this is not just
men's work and but when they really just
prefer something else
we're guilting them and what would be an
example of guilting women into going
into stem like and what way of women
been guilted into going into stem yeah
so I hear multiple anecdotes of people
that went into stem or coding simply to
show that women can do it and then they
end up dropping out later because if
they didn't go into it because they were
passionate about it they were just into
it because they were pushed into it but
I'm surprised to hear you as a you know
former senior engineer right at Google
to use a few anecdotes that you've heard
of to show that the guilting of women is
really the problem you described it to
be like I know of one man who went into
nursing because he felt there aren't
enough male nurses because of the stigma
that women make better nurses but the
fact that I know that one guy doesn't
really tell me anything empirically does
it well yes but so we can go off of we
don't need to use anecdotes we can look
at the dropout rate of tech and it's
much higher for women and when you look
at their reason why it's often that they
simply want a different type of career
so there's differences in what type of
career men and women want and the field
the stem is often characterizes is
realistic and that's one that has a
large gender gap so realistic being you
know working with systems and things and
if you look at the women that drop out
the biggest predictor is whether or not
they want a career in realistic fields
okay let's pass a little to James the
more former senior software engineer at
Google we will take a break and continue
our conversation with the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
there's an interesting bulk politics
story I want to talk about September
25th the date has been set for a
referendum on the independence of the
Iraqi Kurdistan and that day is getting
closer and closer it's uh just days away
at this point Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu who I am no fan of as
you know I won't restate why most of you
already know that said last week that
Israel supports the creation of an
independent Kurdish state a country for
the Kurds right an independent Kurdistan
and this isn't hugely shocking back in
2004 Benjamin Netanyahu said that the
Kurds deserve their own State so he's
been consistent and it's also not just
Benjamin Netanyahu that has this
position a few days ago Justice Minister
Ayelet shaked said during a conference
at the interdisciplinary center in Hertz
Leah that Israel and countries of the
West have a major interest in the
establishment of the state of Kurdistan
I think that the time has come for the
u.s. to support the process the
connections between Israel and the Kurds
go back about 50 years and in the 1960s
Israel had covert relationships with
some Kurdish factions and there are sort
of some overlaps in ideology as well if
you survey the Kurds compared to other
Iraqis you would see that the Kurds are
way more likely to want separation of
mosque and state right their version of
church and state this is interesting for
a number of reasons number one in one
sense it makes sense that Israel would
support an independent Kurdistan right
there's this shared history of
statelessness as well as a persecution
that was the driving force in the
creation of Israel so that part is
logical and there's another angle as
well Mosul
has basically fallen in Iraq and that's
been a big drag down of Isis in the
region if you think about adding to that
Kurdistan as an independent state it
even more fragments the region and it
arguably negatively impacts Iran as well
and you can see the evidence that Iran
is sort of understanding this because
Major General Mohammad
Bagheri whose Iran's Armed Forces
general staff chief has called this
referendum for an independent Kurdistan
quote unacceptable Iran doesn't want it
and it's very clear why the leader of
Iraq's national wisdom stream who's amar
al Hakim has actually suggested that
Israel itself had a part in instigating
the referendum anybody surprised right
you never want to lose an opportunity if
you are Iran or Iraq or whoever you
never want to lose an opportunity to say
it's actually the Jews that are behind
whatever it is else it is that's going
on and there's a lot to be debated about
how much an independent Kurdistan would
actually impact Iran but there are those
who are reflectively anti Israeli and
they see Oh Israel supports an
independent Kurdistan and they say well
you know why Israel wants that right
they want to seed chaos and lack of
unity among Israel's enemies of course
the other position which is much less
conspiratorial is that listen having
another official independent entity in
the region that's not openly hostile to
Israel that's just a good thing
regardless of your view on Israeli
foreign policy the Kurds are generally
sort of comparatively secular they
almost completely identify as Muslim but
remember that secular is not a theist
secular refers to separation of religion
and government so there's actually a
pretty obvious alignment between Israel
and an independent Kurdistan certainly
more than what the flat-out Israel
haters are making it out to be and I
find the the discussion of the Kurds to
be a really really interesting one and
we've talked about this on the program
many times before we did an interview a
really good interview actually with
Steven Mansfield on the YouTube channel
members also would have access to the
full show archive it's called can we
trust the Kurds to fight Isis and it was
a story we did I did not have the
highest expectations of how much
attention it would get I thought it was
a really important interview to do with
Steven Mansfield but the interview has
done in
credibly well the issue of the Kurds is
very interesting there have been some
really good investigative pieces about
the Kurds certainly by sixty minutes I
think by maybe PBS Frontline as well
we've covered it and I think that this
is going to be when you think about the
future of the Middle East there are a
number of different sort of discussions
to have Isis what happens in Egypt what
happens in Iran the israeli-palestinian
conflict the influence of Saudi Arabia
but certainly on the list is the future
of an independent Kurdistan and I
encourage you to check out that
interview okay we've got a voicemail
number that number is two one nine to
david p let's take a listen to this
voicemail and i want to present this to
you what do i want to say about it this
is Troy York okay regular caller Troy
York here is Troy York he seems to think
that he's figured out the real problem
with polarized politics in the United
States and maybe no surprise to some of
our viewers the problem is that I'm a
foreigner causing problems in the u.s.
take a listen to this yes mr. nettinger
lack of knowledge on politics and
traditionally how politics is run is
inexcusable you have no knowledge it's
because of people like you mostly
foreigners huh it's why we have this bar
bipartisan political division that can't
get nothing done what Trump is
attempting to do is return to the days
where Democrats Republicans actually
work together as they're supposed to
them to get legislation and deals done
right listing your podcast again shows
your me your Lanka's now it's
inexperience in even discussing these
subjects and you really should be
working at a drive-thru at a Hardee's
mr. Peck me by person politics gets
nothing done in deal-making
is essential for democracy
ashlee one has more than one political
party but I guess coming from all right
let's kind of that's good you know
somehow I don't think the fact that I
was born in Argentina is the source of
lack of bipartisanship in the United
States it's it's very difficult for me
to believe that that's the case
sounds to me like Troy York has to plug
his phone in yeah he was on low battery
there you gotta get kind of plug your
phone I love Troy York I really do he
calls up with this stuff and it's so out
of nowhere all of a sudden the problem
is that I once visited Israel all of a
sudden the problem with American
politics is that I was born in Argentina
I I kind of envy being able to reduce
all of our problems into such simple
simple explanation maybe we should start
flattering him more and then he'll go
away
I mean that's how you have to treat the
trolls right he seems to only call back
because we say we discredit every single
voicemail that he leaves he'll call back
with his other what is his his a
Hispanic character oh no
Luis eyford has this carrots a Caesar I
don't remember but Troy York has three
or four different characters that he
calls in with anyway on today's bonus
show yet another incident where a sign
language interpreter was communicating
nothing with his hand signals and a
report claims that 40 percent of
American adults sleep with a teddy bear
and I have a very difficult time
believing that that's the case those
stories and also a discussion about some
format changes to the David Pakman show
all upcoming on the bonus show david
pakman.com slash membership to sign up
and of course patreon.com slash david
pakman show also now gives you access
the bonus show and the commercial free
CD show sign up whichever ways best for
you
the bonus shows them
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you